so not one not 100 but more than a
thousand prosecutors have had it with
Donald Trump and his Attorney General
William bar and have signed a letter
condemning both of them over the Roger
stone case and of course the letter is
not going to actually achieve anything
but it does tell us a lot about the
total failure of many of the systems
that we basically take for granted in
our country because no one has ever
challenged them or floated them the way
that the Trump administration has
remember that Donald Trump is connected
to is an associate of Roger stones or
maybe better said Roger stone is an
associate of Donald Trump's Roger stone
was indicted and he was convicted and
prosecutors recommended seven to nine
years in prison for Roger stone and
Roger stone of course has created this
entire campaign to argue how unfair
everything is Trump lost it on Twitter
the Justice Department got involved and
very quickly the recommendation went
from being seven to nine years in prison
time to simply a recommendation for some
prison time this led to multiple
prosecutors saying we can't be involved
in this resigning from the case
altogether and remember that we're
supposed to have separation of powers
and checks and balances here in the
United States we're supposed to have
independence between agencies and
branches of government it's sort of US
government 101 a lot of us learned this
in seventh grade the Justice Department
is separate from the administration the
president gets to pick the Attorney
General who heads the Justice Department
but the Justice Department should be
independently operating investigating
wrongdoing whoever it is that may have
carried it out whether it's members of
an administration or not the Justice
Department should not interfere or exert
influence in individual cases especially
for politically motivated reasons such
as the president doesn't like the
sentence that was recommended for his
associate Roger stone that's how things
are supposed to work but of course the
current form of the Republican Party is
a shameless corrupt colluding
organization that functions more like a
mob family than a major political
parties
Roger stone gets convicted for crimes he
committed in the course of helping
Donald Trump get elected prosecutors
look at the facts and they say based on
the crimes seven to nine years makes
sense and it does and I'll get to that
in a second but Trump catches wind of
this and tweets quote this is a horrible
and very unfair situation the real
crimes were on the other side as nothing
happens to them cannot allow this
miscarriage of justice Donald Trump is
arguing that because people on the other
side politically who have not been
indicted nor charged nor tried nor
convicted of anything they haven't
gotten prison time because this is the
United States and people who aren't
indicted or convicted or tried don't get
prison time stone shouldn't either and
then lo and behold the recommendation
has changed from seven to nine years to
just some prison time and now 1,000
prosecutors more than a thousand
actually are furious Trump says well I
didn't tell the Justice Department to do
this which is of course ridiculous he
doesn't have to the message gets to
William Barr and the Justice Department
that Donald Trump is not pleased the
idea that they are pushing is that the
sentence is out of whack with the crimes
that have been committed but that's not
true let's go through it federal
sentencing guidelines you know sometimes
you hear about these wacky sentences
that are way too light for certain
crimes at in in local courts these
federal sentencing guidelines are very
clear and they use a point system Roger
stone obstructed justice that's 14
points there's an enhancement for
threatening physical injury to a person
that gets Roger stone eight more points
that's 22 three points for interference
with the administration of justice
another two points for extensive
planning of the crime significant
premeditation two points for willfully
obstructing or impeding justice that's
29 points the fact that he has not been
previously convicted puts him in
criminal category 1 and the sentencing
guidelines table says 87 to 108
months that's seven to nine years that's
it there's no real justification for a
lower sentence other than political
cronyism other than this is a guide
Trump's likes at Trump likes and in the
ette and it's likely going to be moot
because remember that Donald Trump can
just pardon him anyway so do not let
yourself be tricked into believing that
this is some unfair sentence being
carried out by some biased jury or an
activist judge we'll get to those
allegations a little bit later what is
wrong and unfair is that Donald Trump is
getting involved what is wrong and
unamerican and unconstitutional is that
Donald Trump is arguing that because his
political enemies who have not been
charged with any crime art in prison
Roger stone shouldn't get 7 to 9 years
and this is just the tip of the iceberg
Donald Trump has an enemies list that he
wants the Justice Department to go after
he has fired impeachment witnesses he's
attacked the foreperson of the Roger
stone jury he says he can intervene in
any case for any reason if he so pleases
it's a disgustingly authoritarian turn
and that's what I want to dig into next
in more detail one of our sponsors today
is a game called lawgivers a turn based
political simulation game for PC iOS and
Android if you've ever wanted to start a
political party or run for office or
shape the destiny of our country here's
your chance I've been having a ton of
fun with the game you do get to
experience legislative democracy up
close and the dynamics of the game are
really impressive you make election
promises to your constituents it's up to
you whether you keep those promises when
you're in office all of the laws you
pass affect your country's happiness and
safety health care environment you can
abolish laws that are already in place
you can ratify the Constitution you
decide if you want the government to be
a healthy democracy or authoritarian
tyranny you can be corrupt and take
bribes political assassinations are part
of the game it's nuts actually it's a
really good time it doesn't get old
because you'll never play it the same
way twice this is not some cheesy
free-to-play game
it's very clear that a lot of time went
into the development it has very
positive reviews on Steam and in the App
Store's four and a half stars or higher
on all platforms go to david pakman.com
slash game which is where you can watch
the trailer download the game for Steam
iOS and Android
that's david pakman.com slash game